[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend der
Krieg zwischen Israel und der Hamas geht
weiter und er wird vermutlich auch noch
lange weitergehen wenn vielleicht auch
nicht mehr so heftig wie im Moment noch
darüber will ich gleich mit dem Sprecher
der israelischen Streitkräfte reden wann
sind diese Ziele dieses Krieges erreicht
und wie steht es um das
schifahkrankenhaus in Gaza auf das sich
im Moment die Aufmerksamkeit der
Weltöffentlichkeit richtet eigene
Eindrücke aus dem Norden Gazas konnte
heute unsere Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf
sammeln sie gehörte zu einer Gruppe
Journalisten die dort mit der
israelischen Armee unterwegs waren
unbegleitet auf eigene Faust sozusagen
können Reporter in das Kriegsgebiet
derzeit nicht
einreisen die israelischen Soldaten
führen uns durch ein Dorf ind dem sie
ein unterirdisches Tunnelsystem entdeckt
und zerstört haben und auch wenn sie die
Kontrolle über diesen Teil Gazastreifens
übernommen haben die schwierigste
Mission steht noch bevor in gazastadt
wollen sie die Infrastruktur der Hamas
zerstören Gaza hat eine Metro eine ganze
unterirdische Stadt wir wissen nicht wo
die einzelnen Löcher sind das heißt Sie
können jederzeit von jedem Bereich der
Stadt auftauchen und uns
überraschen wegen der ständigen Gefahr
bewegen auch wir uns in Panzern der
israelischen Armee
fort Spannung der Männer ist zu spüren
über einen Monitor überwachen sie die
Situation und halten über Funkkontakt
wir wollen tief in den gazastrafen
hinein bis nach gazastadt die Hochburg
der
Hamas wir als Journalisten können uns
hier im Gazastreifen nicht frei bewegen
wir müssen hier mit der israelischen
Armee uns fortbewegen und die zeigt uns
natürlich nur das was sie möchte das
Journalisten sehen ihnen ist es wichtig
vor allem zu zeigen dass die israelische
Armee Rücksicht auf die Zivilbevölkerung
nimmt gilard pasastn ist der Kommandant
der Brigade 808 der
38-Jährige nimmt uns mit an den
östlichen Rand von gazastadt um uns den
humanitären Korridor zu zeigen seine
Männer überwachen die Straße aus
sicherer Entfernung denn immer wieder
mischen sich auch hamaskämpfer unter die
Flüchtenden wir hoffen dass die meisten
Palästinenser von Norden in den Süden
gehen nur so können wir sie schützen vor
der
Hamas es sind mindestens 1000 Menschen
die an uns vorbeiziehen viele schwenken
weiße Fahnen als ob sie damit verhindern
könnten angegriffen zu werden von
unserer Position aus können wir Babys
weinen hören hier im Hintergrund sieht
man den humanitären Korridor den die
israelische Armee hier eröffnet hat es
sind Menschen die aus dem Norden Gazas
in den Süden fliehen
wollen und immer wieder die Durchsage
des
Kommandanten wenn sich hier im Konvoi
Geiseln befinden Menschen die entführt
wurden rennt zu den Soldaten habt keine
Angst die Geiseln zu befreien das hat
für alle Soldaten die ich an diesem Tag
treffe Priorität jeder von ihnen kennt
Menschen die entführt verletzt oder
getötet wurden am 7 Oktober deshalb
kämpfen sie hier damit ihr Land wieder
sicher wird sagen sie
uns so und eigentlich wollten wir jetzt
live zu einer Militärbasis in Israel
verbunden sein mit Colonel Peter lörner
das verzögert sich aber noch ein
bisschen darum erstmal nach Tel Aviv zu
Katrin Eigendorf Katrin diese diese
Reise sage ich mal heute in den
Gazastreifen was hattest du insgesamt
für ein Eindruck die israelische Armee
sagt ja sie habe diesen Norden jetzt
relativ unter
Kontrolle also ich kann mir natürlich
keinen Eindruck darüber machen ob sie
den Norden unter Kontrolle hat weil
soweit sind wir gar nicht gekommen das
Ziel der israelischen Armee war hier uns
vor allem zu zeigen was die Situation
rund um Gaza Stadt ist also das Ziel ist
ja im Prinzip Gaza Stadt so weit unter
Kontrolle zu bringen dass man in der
Lage ist die Infrastruktur der Hamas
dort zu zerstören aber dafür ist es eben
wichtig dass die Zivilisten gazastadt
verlassen und
ähm wir waren mit der Brigade 808
unterwegs und die haben uns mitgenommen
in den Osten von g Stadt und da konnten
wir uns einen Eindruck davon machen was
hat es nun wirklich mit diesem
humanitären Korridor auf sich der
humanitäre Korridor scheint zu
funktionieren also in dem Moment als wir
da waren waren würde ich mal sagen
mindestens 1000 Menschen die an uns
vorbeigingen dort und dieser Zug hat
sich auch den ganzen Tag fortgesetzt das
hat man ja auch im Beitrag gesehen und
das Ziel der Armee ist im Prinzip dafür
zu sorgen dass die Menschen den Norden
verlassen damit sie nicht im Prinzip
zwischen die Hamas Kämpfer und die
israelische Armee kommen bei Kämpfen
dieses Ziel da kommt man immer näher die
Armee sagt im Prinzip auch dass sie die
Kontrolle immer weiter hat aber als wir
dort unterwegs waren habe ich auch
gemerkt wie viel Nervosität herrscht
also wir haben uns dann z.B mit einem
Panzer fortbewegt ja und die Soldaten
haben halt immer wieder geguckt von
diesem Panzer aus was rundherum passiert
also das ist auch nicht ganz
ungefährlich gewesen das glaube ich
gerne Katrin wir hören dass wir jetzt zu
diesem Militärbasis in Israel wechseln
können danke erstmal für deine Eindrücke
aus Gaza und dann begrüße ich jetzt
colel Peter Lerner Oberstleutnant und
Sprecher der israelischen streitkäfte
good evening K you can hear
meel das erklärte Ziel der israelischen
Armee ist ja die Hamas auszuschalten zu
vernichten die Frage die sich stellt ist
woran bemisst man das wann ist der Punkt
wo man sagt ja jetzt
reicht wir verfolgen zwei Ziele mit
diesem Krieg um den wir nicht gebeten
haben und den wir nicht geplant haben
Hamas als
Terrororganisation als beherrschende
Autorität im gazreifen zu stören und
dann
239 Geiseln heimzuholen die dort
gehalten werden wir bewerten jeden Tag
wir bringen mehr Hamas Terroristen um
nehmen ihre Infrastruktur ihre
Fähigkeiten auseinander in den letzten
Tagen haben wir mehr als ihrer
Kommandoposten überrant wir gehen
schrittweise vor wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich was den Erfolg der
Operation angeht und ganz ehrlich es
gibt ja keine Alternative
es gibt Militärbeobachter die sagen dass
sie in Gaza weniger Gegenwehr von Hamas
Terroristen bekommen als erwartet istens
ist das so erstens und zweitens wenn ja
was ziehen Sie daraus für ein Schluss
dass die sich in den Tunneln
verbarrikadieren oder dass sie nach
Süden auch geflohen
sind so ein stadtkrieg und dieser Feind
das ist so dass man sich im zivilen Raum
verschan wir erwarten ein Kampf am Boden
unter dem Boden jeden Tag Begegnungen
mit den Terroristen ja sie haben in der
Tat
ein ganz spektakuläres Bauprojekt in
Gase gemacht was sie dort die Metro
nennen diese Tunnel da verstecken sich
auch von dort aus greifen Sie unsere
Leute an die kommen raus aus den Tunnel
feuern pzer auf Soldaten und
verschwinden gleich wieder ich würde
sagen die Bemühungen laufen es sind sehr
intensive Bemühungen das ist kein
leichter Kampf wir haben etwa 40
Soldaten und Offiziere die schon im
Kampf gefallen sind also es passiert
viel sehr ernsthaft diese aufinand diese
aufeinander PR
aber wir sind stark und sehr
entschlossen unsere Ziele zu erreichen
wie gesagt Hamers muss weg
wir müssen das Paradigma dieser
Terrororganisation
ändern die die ganze Region bedroht das
Volk von palätiner und von Gaza viel
Aufmerksamkeit richtet sich Moment auf
das Krankenhaus in schifa Win sich das
ganze Dilemma zeigt ein Krieg zu führen
während rundherum Zivilisten sind die
Ärzte dort sagen man kommt dort nicht
raus es gibt Luftangriffe es ist das
Krankenhaus ist von Panzern umzingelt
und wenn man versucht vor die Tür zu
gehen wird geschossen von wem dann auch
immer wie wollen Sie mit dieser
Situation speziell auch mit diesem
Krankenhaus
umgehenenhaus ist ein absolut zentrale
Narbe wir haben das der ganzen Welt
kommuniziert das Ausmaß der Operationen
von dort ist riesengroß aber es ist ja
ein ganzer
Komplex der Zugang gibt zur Umgebung das
ist der Modus Operandi in unter
Krankenhäusern und ähnlichen Locations
wir pushen nach vorn aber
wir haben einen freien Zugang gelassen
den östlichen Ausgang da können die
Leute das Krankenhaus verlassen und wir
haben tausende gesehen die das
Krankenhaus diesen compound verlassen
haben um sich woanders in Sicherheit zu
bringen im Gazastreifen im Idealfall im
Süden aber die Lage um das Krankenhaus
herum ist ein perfektes Beispiel dafür
wie wir vorgehen gerade in der letzten
Nacht in den frühen Morgenstunden haben
wir 300 l Sprit gebracht damit man dort
die Generatoren betreiben kann Hamas
bedroht dort die Verantwortlichen im
Krankenhaus und verhindert das
Einbringen von Gütern will nur deutlich
machen warum es denen geht zuschlagen
Israelis töten gazam Menschen töten das
Hospital das Hospital wir müssen die
Leute rausbringen das ist ganz klar wir
sagen nun schon seit vier Wochen
verlasst das Krankenhaus es ist
unverzichtbar dass die Leute das
Krankenhaus evakuieren wir versuchen da
zuu koordinieren zu helfen und wir
freuen uns wenn wir sehen dass tausende
unsere Aufrufe angehört haben und das
Krankenhaus verlassen haben eine riesen
Herausforderung für jedes Militär aber
wir wollen haben besegen das bringt uns
einen Schritt dem Ziel näher wissen wir
alle dass es keine sauberen kriege gibt
wo nur präzise die getroffen werden die
getroffen werden sollen auch wenn man
die Zahlen der Hamas jetzt nicht eins zu
eins übernehmen will die sagen wir in
zwischen über 11000 Tote im Gazastreifen
es werden sehr sehr sehr viele Menschen
sein die sterben und beweiten nicht nur
hamaskämpfer zivile Opfer in diesem
Krieg sind eine reine
Katastrophe da gibt es keine
Umschreibung das kann niemand anders aus
drücken dramatische Bilder die aus Gaza
kommen und die Zivilisten zahlen einen
hohen Preis aufgrund dieser
Kriegserklärung Hamas gegen Israel wir
tun alles was wir können unsere sehr
professionellen militärischen
Werte besagen dass wir unterscheiden
zwischen nichtkbattanten Zivilisten und
Soldaten dann muss jedes Ziel auch
erreichbar sein und äh das gilt auf dem
äh Schlachtfeld aber auch in der
generellen strategischen Verteidigung
und dann die
Verhältnismäßigkeit was können und
müssen wir tun um die Ziele zu erreichen
die Zivilisten zahlen einen hohen Preis
ein Preis den Hamers mit dieser
Entscheidung des Angriffs gegen uns
beschlossen hat als Ergebnis dieses
Verhaltens von Hamas brutal uns zu
überfallen zu vergewaltigen zu
massakrieren zu morden das ist das
Ergebnis le ist das so aber wir haben
keine Alternative müssen dieses
Paradigma ändern sagt der Sprecher der
israelischen Streitkräfte colel Peter
Lerner danke ihn für das
Gespräch danke
schön Israels Regierungschef Benjamin
Netanyahu deutete heute an dass es
irgendeine Form von Deal geben könnte um
Geiseln frei zuekommen ob daraus etwas
wird steht in den Sternen aber für die
Angehörigen ist das natürlich die große
Hoffnung an die sie sich klammern dass
es zu irgendeiner Vereinbarung kommt das
Gespräche mit dem Emirat Qatar
vielleicht etwas bringen das aus dem
westlichen Ausland Druck kommt unter den
Geiseln sind bekanntlich auch Menschen
mit deutscher Staatsbürgerschaft ihre
Familien hoffen dass auch die
Bundesregierung etwas ausrichten kann
einige Angehörige sind von Israel nach
Berlin und München gekommen um Politiker
zu treffen und um Hilfe zu
z und alexandralin
berichten seit mehr als einem Monat
vermisst Nama ihren Cous er ist Geisel
der Hamas einer von etwa
240 es sind 36 Tage vergangen seit dem 7
Oktober und sie sind immer noch nicht
zurück also sind die Solidarität und die
Unterstützung noch nicht
genug sind nach Deutschland gekommen
erhoffen sich Unterstützung politisch
diplomatisch und treffen auf ein Land
das zerrissen ist vom Nahostkonflikt und
in diesen Tagen Geschichten erzählt die
nicht passen wollen zum nie wieder meine
Enkelin ist die ich aus Israel die
ersten Tage herausgeholt habe wo ich
gedacht habe sie bleibt ein paar Wochen
hier ist wieder zurückgefahren mit dem
mit den Worten ich fühle mich in Israel
sicherer als hier in mchen Detail hat
sie Angst gehab wenn die
Kinder heäisch sprechen auf der Straße
dass das Folgen für Sie haben wird 85
Jahre nach der Reichsprogromnacht Leben
Juden in Deutschland in Angst auch wenn
die Repräsentanten des Staates fest an
ihrer Seite
stehen und wenn wie an diesem Wochenende
in München an die Opfer der Hamas
erinnert wird kommen gerade mal ein paar
Dutzend
Menschen gleichen Tag versammeln sich
tausende zu proalästina Demos und
erheben die Klage dass das Leid der
Zivilisten in Gaza nicht gesehen werde
als Deutscher mit Migrationshintergrund
aus dem gaserastreifen der jetzt auch
Familienmitglieder vor Ort verloren hat
hat man nicht die Möglichkeit im offenen
Raum auch seine Trauer zu verarbeiten
und wenn man da nach außen hin irgendwie
auch in der Arbeit irgendwie da den
Zuspruch sucht stößt man wirklich gegen
eine Wand leider Gottes und Dialog gibt
es kaum Benjamin Idris ist Imam und gilt
als Kämpfer für die Verständigung
zwischen den Religionen in diesen Tagen
scheitert er daran ein Friedensgebet
gemeinsam mit Muslimen Juden und
Christen geplatzt und weit und breit
niemand der vermittelt die Politik hat
die Aufgabe Brückenbauer zu sein
zwischen muslimisch und jüdischen
Mitbürger hier und die Politik macht in
diesen Richtung fast gar
nichts und Muslime fühlen sich
allein auch die muslimische Gemeinde
bangt um ihre Sicherheit immer mehr
Hassbotschaften z.B euch soll man aus
dem Land jagen ihr Antisemiten ihr seid
nicht ehrlich pfui Teufel wir können
nicht
mehr wir müssen uns seit Jahrzehnten in
diesem Land beaupten wer wir nicht sind
wir sind nicht für Gewalt wir sind nicht
für Terror ja eigentlich doch
selbstverständlich Muslime unter
Generalverdacht Juden in Angst
Deutschland 36 Tage nach dem Überfall
der Hamas der Terror richtet sich nicht
nur gegen sie sagen die Angehörigen
heute sondern gegen uns
alle laufend aktuelle Informationen zu
diesem und anderen Themen finden Sie
natürlich wie immer auch online auf ztf
heute oder in der ztf heute App
die massiven Demonstrationen teils mit
anti-israelischen antisemitischen und
islamistischen Tönen oder zur Schau
getragenen Symbolen beschäftigen weiter
auch die Politik und mit dem Thema
beginnen jetzt bei dir die Nachrichten
ja bundesinnenministerin fäer hat sich
vor dem Hintergrund antisemitischer
Vorfälle bei proalästinensischen
Demonstrationen grundsätzlich offen für
eine Änderung des Strafrechts gezeigt in
der zdfsendung Berlin direkt sagte fäer
schnelle Strafen und tatsächliche
Verurteilungen seien wichtig wenn man
dafür das Strafrecht ändern müsse dann
sei sie dafür so fäer zudem unterstützte
sie die Forderung der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei nach bundesweit einheitlichen
Regeln bei
Demonstrationen das Versammlungsrecht
ist mittlerweile bei den Ländern ich
werde in der nächsten
Innenministerkonferenz dafür werben dass
es diese rote Linie überall einheitlich
geben muss weil sonst die Menschen auch
ähm Vertrauen in den Rechtsstaat
verlieren und das halte ich dieser Tage
für unheimlich wichtig ich möchte dass
Jüdinnen und Juden sich in Deutschland
sicher
fühlen eine große Kundgebung gegen
Antisemitismus hat es heute in Paris
gegeben mehr als 100.000 Menschen
beteiligten sich angeführt wurde der
Protestzug von Spitzenpolitikern und den
ehemaligen Präsidenten saroszi und Oland
seit Beginn des Krieges am 7 oktober
wurden in Frankreich mehr als 1200
antisemitische Vorfälle registriert
darunter Gewalttaten Pöbeleien und
schmierereinen
in Deutschland wird zur Würdigung der
Leistungen von Soldatinnen und Soldaten
wohl bald ein Veteranentag eingeführt
Ampel und Union sind dafür und wollen in
der kommenden Woche Details ausarbeiten
als Datum ist der heutige 12 november im
Gespräch das Gründungsdatum der
Bundeswehr im Jahr
1955 die Bundesregierung will nach
Medienberichten die Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine im kommenden Jahr verdoppeln die
demnach sollen die Ausgaben von 4 auf 8
Milliarden Euro steigen damit würden die
Verteidigungsausgaben
2,1% des Bruttoinlandsproduktes betragen
etwas mehr als das erklärte natoziel von
mindestens 2%. der geplanten Erhöhung
muss noch der Haushaltsausschuss
zustimmen der
Literaturnobelpreisträger Abdul rassak
gurnna hat in der diesjährigen Schiller
Rede gefordert alle Verbrechen der
deutschen Kolonialherrschaft auf
zuarbeiten die aus Namibia dem
ehemaligen deutschsüdwestafrika sein
zwar bekannt nahe zu vergessen sein
hingegen die Taten im früheren
deutschostafrika heute Tansania Burundi
und Ruanda kritisierte gurna im
Literaturarchiv mabach er selbst stammt
aus dem heutigen Tansania seine Romane
behandeln Kolonialismus Migration und
Identität bei der EKD Synode in Ulm hat
die Ratsvorsitzende der Evangelischen
Kirche kurschuss das Engagement für
geflüchtete bekräftigt gleichzeitig
stellte sie klar dass sie nicht für eine
unbegrenzte Zuwanderung sei aber gegen
die Festlegung einer Obergrenze die nach
ihrer Ansicht nicht mit deutschem und
EU-Recht vereinbar wäre vier Tage lang
treffen sich die Delegierten des
evangelischen Kirchenparlaments in Ulm
neben politischen Themen geht es um die
Entwicklung der Mitgliederzahlen sowie
einen neuen
Haushalt die Ratsvorsitzende der
Evangelischen Kirche Frau Kurschus
forderte zum Auftag der Synode auch ein
entschiedeneres Engagement gegen
Antisemitismus und warnte zugleich vor
einem als israelf Freundlichkeit
getarmten Hass auf Muslime Rassismus
Antisemitismus
Ausländerfeindlichkeit natürlich sind
das Themen für die Kirchen für Politik
und politische Organisationen für
Sozialverbände oder Soziologen das ist
sozusagen der erwartbare Raum in dem
solche Debatten geführt und angestoßen
werden doch inzwischen äußert sich dazu
auch die deutsche Wirtschaft und schaut
dabei naturgemäß auf die wirtschaftliche
Bedeutung von Einwanderung so warnen
unter anderem Mittelständler in
Baden-Würtemberg vor den Folgen einer
zunehmend feindseligen Stimmung Eva
Schiller
berichtet abschieben und abschotten
diese Dauerdiskussion macht uns Angst
sagt SAR bra sie leitet die Produktion
beim bergsportausstatter vd ist
Marokkanerin in ihrem Team arbeiten
Menschen aus 30 Nationen eins ein alle
ob eingewanderte Fachkraft oder
Flüchtling sie spüren wachsende
Ausländerfeindlichkeit ich finde schon
dass alle in einen Topf geworfen werden
und natürlich macht es auch was mit der
Stimmung weil das menschliche einfach so
verloren geht weil am Ende des Tages
geht es hier um Menschen die einfach
flüchten vor dem Krieg oder sonstiges
das Unternehmen Musterbeispiel für
Integration Chefin von David eine
liberale vordenkerin unter den
Mittelständlern sie fordert statt
ständig zu jammern müssen Unternehmen
jetzt für Offenheit eintreten wer möchte
denn in ein Land kommen das so nach
außen schreit ihr seid hier nicht
willkommen also das ist einfach sehr
sehr
kurzsichtig man spricht so auf von
Deindustrialisierung durch steigende
Energiepreise die Gefahr ist viel größer
dass wir deindustrialisieren weil wir
uns die Arbeitskräfte fehlen lange haben
Wirtschaftsvertreter geschwiegen das
ändert sich langsam mehr und mehr Nehmer
im Südwesten warnen vor Fremden
feindlicher Stimmung bei Stiel
Weltmarktführer für Motorsägen merken
Sie die Unsicherheit auch in der
Belegschaft sie merken dass die
populistischen Parolen der AFD verfangen
und möchten ein Zeichen setzen wir
brauchen Fachkräfte
Zuwanderung und wir brauchen nicht
diesen Protektionismus und vor allem die
mesestimmung die die AFD verbreitet man
muss ganz klar sagen die AFD ist eine
riesig für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland
860.000 Fachkräfte werden Berechnungen
zufolge bis
205 allein in Baden-Würtemberg fehlen
die Firma Richter tief in der
schwäbischen Provinz weiß was es heißt
um die besten Kräfte zu buolen sie
entwickeln hochwertige
Architekturkonzepte neben ukrainischen
it arbeitet der indische Ingenieur und
der kumbianische Architekt wir müssen
natürlich überlegen warum soll sich den
entscheiden nach Deutschland zu kommen
und wir sehen momentan wir haben auch
schon einige z.B Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine die bei uns angekommen sind die
haben wir an Kanada verloren
hochqualifizierte Mitarbeiter wo Kanada
einfach alles einfacher macht die
Richters versuchen alles damit ihre
Fachkräfte nicht an der deutschen
papierformularbürokratie
[Musik]
verzweifeln nach vihalb Monaten habe ich
einen Brief bekommen dass sie meine
Papiere verloren haben deswegen sollte
ich meine Unterlagen einreichen sie
haben mir einen Termin gegeben fürs
nächste
Jahr mit der Digitalisierung das ist ein
Punkt D ich finde in Deutschland schwer
ohne Digitalisierung ist ist ein
bisschen kompliziert in einer eigens
gezimmerten Almhütte halten die Richters
ihre Mitarbeiter bei Laune sie fordern
eine
Willkommenskultur digitale Behörden um
wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben die
Unternehmer sind überzeugt wenn
Deutschland Einwanderer auswählt und
einfliegt dann würden weniger Menschen
übers Meer
flüchten und jetzt geht's bei dir noch
mal weiter Heinz zuerst zur Fußball
buundesliga da bleibt Bayern Leverkusen
an der Tabellenspitze nach einem 4:0
Sieg heute gegen Union Berlin das jetzt
ganz unten steht in den beiden anderen
Sonntagsspielen trennten sich Werder
Bremen und Eintracht Frankfurt
Unentschieden 2:2 und Leipzig gewann
gegen Freiburg
3:1 Skirennläuferin Lena D ist auch beim
zweiten Weltcup slalum im finnischen
Leevi aufs Protest gefahren die
32-Jährige fuhr einen Tag nach ihrem
zweiten Platz heute am Ende auf Rang 3
dabei profitierte D davon dass die in
Führung liegende vortagessiegerin Petra
willowa aus der Slowakei im zweiten
Durchgang ausschied den Sieg sicherte
sich Ausnahme Skifahrerin Mikaela
Schiffrin aus den
USA früher und das steht ganz außer
Frage früher war die Welt noch in
Ordnung früher war mehr Lametta es gab
kosackenzipfel und ein Klavier es saugte
und blie der Heinzelmann die Ente blieb
draußen und das Ei kochte viereinhalb
Minuten und keine Sekunde mehr Mutter
wir danken dir und sollte die Dame des
Hauses doch noch etwas Eigenes wollen
dann machte sie ein Jodeldiplom Holler
Dudel lorio und seine kongeniale
Partnerin evely unvergessen
unerreicht heute wäre Vico von bülo 100
Jahre alt geworden Claudio Armbruster
mit einer omage an den Fernsehmann lorio
der dieses Medium so treffsicher zu
nutzen und zu persiflieren wusste
entschuldigen Sie ich bin vom deutschen
Fernsehen ach das tut mir leid ich habe
gar kein Kleingeld bei mir für den Fall
dass an Ihrem Fernsehgerät aufgrund
atmosphärischer Umweltbelastungen Bild
und Tonstörungen auftreten können Sie
diese mühelos selbst beheben nach
Entfernen des astigmatischen
ablenkfeldindikators setzen sie dem
hypertrophalcoder einfach ein zweites
luminansignal zu und justieren am
microswitch den differentiellen
paraboloidphasenfehler durch twisten des
high touchable orticon Transistors ist
unser Interview jetzt
dran ich weiß nicht wann wir im Bild
sind das Rotlicht einer Kamera
funktioniert nicht
Hallo hört mich jemand in der Regie
hallo hier kneift was an der Perücke
vielleicht kann man da irgendwas
Maske hier überm Ohr das haben wir
[Musik]
gleich du hast schon mal was gemacht im
Fernsehen nicht so ab und zu ich habe
gleich gesagt haxmann kenne ich h sag
ich ja ich Ken die alle da ist das
Rotlicht wo da wo ah ja Herr Professor
häubel jetzt habe ich keine Lust mehr es
wird immer wieder behauptet dass
Fernsehen beeinflusse durch seine
Berichterstattung den Wahlkampf und
damit auch das
Wahlergebnis wir haben heute zwei
prominente Funktionäre der beiden großen
Parteien zu uns in Studio gebeten um
über diesen sehr ernsten Vorwurf
sachlich zu diskutieren Herr Graupner
gehört zum inneren Führungsstab der SPD
Herr Müller Meisenbach ist leitender
wahlkampfkoordinator der CDU CS Herr
Professor wir sind auf Sendung und sie
befinden sich in einer rechtlichen
öffentlichen Anstalt na und dies ist ein
öffentliches Haus toll abschalten
schaltet doch eure dämliche Kamera ab
komm junge mach's
bildfrei also das finde ich jetzt
überhaupt nicht toll was Du eben gesagt
hast schon gut dicker sie haben 4
Sekunden Zeit und
bitte Sicherheit für Deutschland jeder
andere wäre froh wenn er seinen Quatsch
über ein Bildschirm verbreiten dürfte
als gut ich bitte um äußerste
Ruhe
sagenhaft ist es geht das ich meine
können Sie das mit jedem Körperteil
natürlich ach passen Sie auf Nein Nein
vielleicht ist es besser ich bitte um
äußerste Ruhe kannst du den Kopf eine
Kleinigkeit höher nehmen D wird Licht
besser halt
mal
hast du heute Abend was vor bitte ver
Herr Müller Meisenbach ich kann Ihnen
noch 3 Sekunden für den Wahlspruch der
CDU Cru geben und
bitte für Frieden und
Freiheit das war zu lang Herr Graupner
sie dürfen ihr letztes Wort ganz kurz
wiederholen Deutschland ja aber viel
kürzer
bitte Deutschland das war eine
Winzigkeit zu
lang her müllerach sie haben jetzt noch
eine Sekunde für Frieden und Freiheit
bitte und damit wünschen wir Ihnen einen
ausgewogenen guten
Abend genauso ist es beim Fernsehen und
man wüsste gern wie lorio heute unserer
Gesellschaft den Spiegel vorhalten würde
wir sind damit fast am Ende unserer
Sendung an diesem Sonntag aber natürlich
nicht ohne einen Ausblick auf die
nächste Woche zu geben Termine und
Ereignisse zusammengestellt von Kamran
safiaran
[Musik]
am Montag beginnt die bundesweite
Aktionswoche zum Schutz von Kindern und
Jugendlichen vor sexueller Gewalt nicht
wegschauen Kindern zuhören und bei
Verdacht Nachfragen dafür sollen Eltern
sensibilisiert werden initiiert wird die
auch vom ZDF unterstützte Kampagne von
Bundesfamilienministerin Lisa Paus und
der Missbrauchsbeauftragten ktin
Klaus ebenfalls am Montag wird sich
bundesaußenministerin
mit ihren EU-Kollegen in Brüssel treffen
auf der Tagesordnung die russische
Aggression gegen die Ukraine der
Nahostkrieg in Gaza aber auch der
Konflikt zwischen Armenien und
Aserbaidschan Strukturwandel in der
Lausitz demokratisches Miteinander im
Osten Themen der Konferenz
Ostdeutschland 2030 am Freitag in
Leipzig Bundeskanzler Scholz diskutiert
unter anderem mit den
Ministerpräsidenten der ostdeutschen
Länder wie der Osten positiver gest t
werden
kann ebenfalls am Freitag wird der
türkische Präsident Erdogan
Bundespräsident Steinmeier und
Bundeskanzler Scholz in Berlin treffen
der Deutschlandbesuch gilt wegen
Erdogans anti-israelischer Haltung als
umstritten erdogan hatte zuletzt die
Hamas als
Befreiungsorganisation Israel dagegen
als Kriegsverbrecher
bezeichnet zum Schluss noch der Blick
aufs Wetter es gibt aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor
ergiebigem Dauerregen in Teilen von
badenwürtemberg und Bayern und jetzt die
Aussichten für morgen der Dauerregen im
Südwesten macht am Vormittag eine kurze
Pause bevor am Nachmittag neuer
kräftiger Regen einsetzt auch sonst
regnet es häufig nur ganz im Nordosten
bleibt es bis zum Abend trocken dazu
weht bei 7 bis 16° ein starker im Westen
auch stürmischer Wind auch die nächsten
Tage bleiben regnerisch der ergiebige
Regen im Süden lässt am Mittwoch nach
mit sech bis 12° am Donnerstag wird es
etwas
kühler das war's im heutejournal am Ende
dieser Woche ab morgen führen Sie hier
Christian Sievers und Hanna Zimmermann
durchs Weltgeschehen und die nächste
heute Express gibt es um 025 auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
wiedersehen